wait who's hotter JLo Shakira it's
Shakira by a million [ __ ] miles dude
away and close JLo is wearing a [ __ ]
maxi pad during her entire performance
did you see that the wings were flapping
out the sides and I couldn't even look
at her ovaries you look only one room
for Shakira yeah because you have to
understand what's going on okay I'm in a
relationship all right okay what I'm
thinking uh I'm not fit you guys are
thinking about JLo you're thinking about
legacy you're thinking about all these
everything about busting nuts doggy
style yo who do you think is gonna make
the nuts bus did you see
Shakira's hips telling the truth all
that shake boom pop pop pop pop so tiny
bro that's the thing like that camera oh
yeah oh yeah she went for it
she went for now here's the thing is
this it that's the thing yeah it wasn't
good you know who she was talking to
[ __ ] ice is broken I really thought
was about to be a terrorist attack and
the super balls like oh she's signaling
them this jail had on that thick makeup
dude look JLo astronomy the [ __ ] on
she's biting the [ __ ] up I think Aaron
Rodriguez got her on some [ __ ] because
she wasn't like this before Aaron no
Aaron a rock a rod a chubby bull these
days he's shall eat Rodriguez Alex I'll
be in the face now yeah he might might
be a little chubby thinner
my point is this Shakira for one [ __ ]
one night of [ __ ] look at the hip
thing you're not gonna experience that
anywhere else
you're not gonna experience that
anywhere else you don't have any big
dudes
JLo has [ __ ] go through the list Ben
Affleck P Diddy [ __ ] everybody Drake
so great when you're bangin with Shakira
but when you're [ __ ] to go you're
thinking about like what guys she's
holstered oh yes why cuz I'm gonna freak
son so you're banging it and you're like
[ __ ] did he was in here like that was
crossed my mind cuz me and Diddy like
the same cars
so if did he took up first I want to
take it for a spin
I see now that's weird see I don't want
to think about Diddy when I'm having sex
no I'll think about him I just go okay
my think about Diddy when I'm on sex is
when I'm looking at a grand I go take
that take that
take it take that take that take that
take that the old ends look at Shakira
dude the way she moves her hips and it
doesn't work in the pictures in the
pictures you're gonna look at JLo but
when you look a location moves it hums
it's about the way she moves the hill I
agree it's not even a question like
you're talking about a unique sexual
experience with that one girl on the
left it is a truly unique experience she
though she's very hips are moving like
crazy don't lie it's gonna be a
different thing your dick never
experienced that in your life JLo
beautiful girl a thousand of hers I mean
you could get a ride presenting that I'm
not gonna write a ticket better than any
other girl from the Bronx I don't know
Oh cardi beats from the Bronx right you
think cardi can't take it down more than
JLo that's what I'm saying you know who
could give cardi run for her money
Shakira right there that Columbia mami
it's not it's and I kinda have a job
right now listen do you a little bit
she's going keep going okay if you got
any gifts or any movement of the hips
you would see what's going on you're
just gonna lay on your back you don't do
you lay on your back you give Shakira
the whole night with her on top you
don't even try to [ __ ] on top you lay on
your back and then she goes to work lazy
all night it's not about lazy it's about
you giving her that back you're right
dude but you gotta let her work I mean
oh it's just different
she's just tiny so look look just like a
little amazing there's no meat on either
one of them they're super skinny no
Jayla has a little bit of a pop it
here's the other thing hey here's the
other thing what's the other name dude
titties not become cool anymore
everybody flat-chested these days that's
true you like some do you like some jugs
I like like huge knob is really four
years old you thought a big [ __ ] man oh
I like like [ __ ] Beth Chapman like
Doug bounty-hunter tits you know
it's such a reverence dude but like
titties aren't cool anymore what would
you rather have would you rather have I
I personally don't need tits like I want
proportion body but I want lamps I don't
like flat chests I like some cake
oh yeah I like some hips I like some
cake and then if you got a little titty
that's fine that's extra he's an extra
little titties extra titties are like
none yeah you don't want to make like
the fart sound when you're on top of it
yeah no yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]